Musik Das ist die grosse New York-Folge, die New York-Gala. Hör auf jetzt! Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop. Du bist schon wieder so aufgeregt. Halt mich auf, halt mich zurück! Stefan, Stefan, komm mal, leg dich mal ganz kurz hin, ruh dich mal ganz mit. Ich komm noch mal klar. Ich komm noch mal klar. Ich merk schon, du hast einen hochroten Kopf, du hast drei Brillen auf heute, du hast die Haare nicht gemacht, vier Swagways klemmen unter deinen Füssen. Ich habe mein Getränk zu Hause vergessen, zu Hause vergessen, draußen vom Raum vergessen. Kann ich dein Getränk vielleicht? Ich gehe nochmal raus, atme nochmal tiefgehörig, komm nochmal rein. Sie hören gleich, eine fantastische Anmoderation von Stefan Tietze, freuen Sie sich drauf. Der Mann, das junge Nachwuchs, habe ich letztens gelesen, das junge Nachwuchstalent Stefan Tietze. Hey, danke, bleibt ruhig sitzen. Ich bin's doch nur, euer Stefan, das Fun steht wie immer für fantastische Gags. Ich freue mich vor uns, wenn wir zu einer neuen Folge zusammengekommen sind, ich trinke kurz einen Schluck. Weil es so warm draußen ist und dann trocknet man ein, wie eine Pflanze. Was sind die drei grossen Peer des Podcastings? Pflanzen, Podcasten, selber, klar, einfach und Porno. Porno? Tatsächlich? Wie viele Pornos hast du dir zur Vorbereitung angeschaut? 23. Warum genau 23? Was ist beim 23. passiert, dass du gesagt hast, du reicht? Na ja, 23 ist erstmal eine Primzahl. Ja? Ja, eine ganze Nation bewegt ihre Augen nach oben rechts bei dieser Aussage. Aber das ist interessant, oben links oder oben rechts, würde mich mal interessieren. Wenn ihr jetzt gerade in der U-Bahn Leute gesehen habt, die auch ihre Augen ruckartig nach oben rechts bewegt haben, dann wisst ihr, ein Podcast-Uferhörer, den es vielleicht anzusprechen und zu umwerben gilt … Hat nachgedacht, ob 23 eine Primzahl ist. Ja, und es ist … eine Primzahl. Ja, eine Primzahl. Eine von vielen, würde ich sagen. Aber warum guckt man denn nach oben links, ist die Frage, weil nämlich da die logische Gehirn ist, weil da das Gehirn ist. Nur oben links. Aber woher weiss das Gehirn, wo die logische Hälfte ist? Das weisst du ja nicht, ist unterbewusst. Weisst du es bestimmt. Nein. Ich habe mal gehört, dass... Nein, nein, nein, ich möchte ganz kurz Ocean's Eleven zitieren. Mach das bitte kurz. Du schaust nach oben links, ähm... Ne, warte, was ist der Unterschied? Das eine war... Das ist gerade alles Ocean's Eleven, er hat auch nachgedacht. Ja, genau, George Clooney ganz kurz, sorry, gib mir eine Sekunde, sorry.
Das ist eine geile Stelle, achte aber auf das Mikro im Bild.
Warte mal ganz kurz, Paul, kannst du nochmal ganz kurz kommen?
Ne, oben links ist, wenn du die Antwort nicht weisst und oben rechts ist, wenn du lügst, glaube ich.
Ja, wenn du gerade einen besseren Gag suchst. Ja genau, das sind die beiden Varianten, entweder du versuchst zu lügen oder du weisst es nicht und denkst dir was Neues aus.
Und wo guckt man hin, wenn man einen besseren Gag sucht? Direkt in die Augen von Matt Damon. Das ist immer die beste Wahl. Direkt auf Witze.com. Unser heutiges Thema hat Stefan mitgebracht tatsächlich heute. Heisst Rodung. Wir schauen uns heute mal an, Brandrodung. Ich finde das spannend. Wo hört es auf, wo fängt es an, was bringt es für Vorteile. Wir alle haben schon mal gerodet, wir alle lieben es zu rodeln. Ich war jetzt wirklich eine Woche konstant mit Stefan unterwegs und das Wort, das man wirklich am meisten hört, ist Rodeln, die ganze Zeit. Rodeln? Irgendwie, oh, lass uns doch ein Quiz machen, wann war die grösste Rodung der Geschichte und du 1926, wie nennt man die Technik die Rodung, es ist immer dasselbe einfach, den ganzen Tag. Das war jetzt im Gett geschuldet, aber wie war es denn wirklich mit mir eine Woche lang in New York? Ich meine, wir mussten sogar in einem Zimmer schlafen. Wir hatten zwar eigene Betten, was nicht ganz... Ich dachte ja, okay, ich bin davon ausgegangen, die Firma bezahlt das. Ich habe mich schon da in den Bademantel über die goldenen Flure flanieren sehen. Was du auch gemacht hast, tatsächlich. Davon hast du dich nicht abhalten lassen. In Harlem, aber es ist eine andere Geschichte, kam nicht gut an mit einem einheimischen, Inuit, sag ich mal, glaube ich. Und dann hatten wir tatsächlich zwei eigene Betten, was nicht geplant war, sondern eigentlich sollten sechs Leute bei uns im Aparten sein, wir waren nachher vier und es war immer noch sehr eng. Die anderen beiden wurden auf dem Weg dahinter erschossen, tatsächlich. Aber das war eigentlich ganz gut. Aber das war ganz gut, weil wir haben uns dann dazu entschlossen, dass wir zusammen ein Zimmer hatten mit jeweils einem Bett, haben uns aber dazu entschlossen, die Tür offen zu lassen, damit nicht so eine beklemmende Seifeatmosphäre aufkommt. Damit niemand denkt, was kann da gerade drin vorgehen, weil sie sehen, was drin vorgeht, weil sie reingucken können. Was tatsächlich dafür geführt hat, dass es noch awkwarder war, weil unsere Mitbewohner dann immer irgendwie nachts aufs Klo gegangen sind und gesehen haben, wie wir wild aufrecht im Bett stehend uns gegenseitig … Selbst befriedigen. Aber das Beste ist echt, wenn Leute denken, du schläfst, aber du siehst, wie sie sich Mühe geben, dich nicht aufzuwecken. Und dann sieht man so verbuschelte Haare, einfach über so einen Haarknäuel sieht man über die Flure schleichen und die einfach nicht hinkriegen. Und das Schönste ist, wenn Leute sich dann auch irgendwo die Zehen anschlagen. Und dann will ich ganz leise Schmerzen. Und bei mir die erste Nacht tatsächlich hatten wir über unserem Herz so eine Lampe und ich bin mitten in der Nacht aufs Tor gegangen und habe diese Lampe nicht ausbekommen, weil ich den Schalter nicht gefunden habe. Und das muss auch lustig ausgesehen haben, wo ich mitten in der Nacht verschlafen irgendwie auf alle möglichen Stellen gedrückt habe, die so eine Küche hat, um diese Lampe auszukriegen, die einfach nicht ausmachbar war. Er erinnert mich tatsächlich an der Geschichte von meinem Onkel, weil vielleicht schon mal mein Onkel hat mal bei mir geschlafen in meinem Bett. Komm, ich zeige dir mal einen richtigen Onkel. Der hat auch eine Menge rumgedrückt, bevor er den richtigen Knopf gefunden hat, sag ich mal. Und ich hatte so rechts, die rechte Wand von mir war so eine riesige Weltkarte, daher kommt auch mein perfektes biografisches Wissen. Dein Spitzname der Weltenkartler. Genau, und da war es eine riesige Weltkarte und tatsächlich war auf der Weltkarte, nur ich wusste, unter Madagaskar ist der Lichtschalter. Also du musstest auf die Weltkarte auf Madagaskar drücken. Da waren die Kondome versteckt. Ach so, was? Lichtschalter? Nee, wir haben tatsächlich keine Kondome benutzt. Aber er hat tatsächlich auf die, man muss auf Madagaskar klicken, klicken, drücken, einfach normal, mit deinem echten Finger. Ja. Oder mit anderen Körpern. So, auf jeden Fall musste man auf Madagaskar drücken, um das Licht an und auszumachen. Und er hatte dringend geschlafen und kam in der Nacht aus Versehen an diesen Lichtschalter und wusste, dann ist der Licht einfach angestrahlt ins Gesicht. Auch Madagaskar, was von so einer Wut von dir gegenüber gegen Madagaskar führt. Ja, aber er wusste ja nicht, wo der Schalter war. Er wusste es einfach nicht und hat einfach überall gesucht und kam natürlich nicht auf die Idee, auf Madagaskar zu drücken. Und du hast die ganze Zeit gerufen, Madagaskar, und er die ganze Zeit, ach man, ich weiss du, was du bei Madagaskar willst, aber ich will nicht Schalter suchen. Ja, Madagaskar, nein, der ist nie auf Madagaskar. Er hat es nicht gerafft, Riesensketch. Er hatte auch was im Mund in der Momentan. So, auf jeden Fall. Du machst eins zu eins gerade den Olaf Schubert. Wirklich? Ja, der macht immer Gags und dann lacht das Publikum natürlich, weil es ein Gag war, aber er macht dann immer so, ist egal und dann macht er weiter, er sieht einen neuen Gag und dann war er ein bisschen so weg. Dankeschön, dankeschön, das ist halt nicht als Kompliment gemeint. Auf jeden Fall finde ich die Situation so lustig, du bist in einem fremden Bett und in der Mitte der Nacht fängt ein Licht an in deine Augen zu strahlen und du kriegst keine Luft mehr. Wie das? Einmal eine Geschichte, im ostdeutschen Dialekt. Irgendwann gesagt, na, das ist immer zu früh, und dann hat er irgendwann die Glühbirne rausgedreht und dann war auch gut. So, auf jeden Fall soll er irgendwann nicht verloren. Aber er zählt seine richtige Glühbirne oder nicht seine richtige Glühbirne rausgezogen. So, auf jeden Fall waren wir zusammen in Harlem in einem Zimmer und es war toll. Wie war es wirklich? Mach mal dein Herz, öffne mal dein Herz. Ja, es war schön auf jeden Fall.. Ich habe sehr gut geschlafen, tatsächlich du ja nicht so, weil du hast dann immer gesagt, das Fenster ist zu weit offen, die Schüsse sind zu laut in der Nacht. Das Problem war, es heisst ja die Stadt, die niemals schläft und ich dachte mir, das hält die Stadt nicht durch. Ich bin eine Woche da, ich kann es testen, das hält die Stadt nicht durch. Sie hat es durchgehalten. Es war rund um die Uhr, kleine Radau, muss ich mal sagen. Leute waren auf den Strassen nachts die ganze Zeit, die sind da sehr nah an der Hupe gebaut, haben andauernd draufgehauen, auch nachts tatsächlich, direkt vorm Haus, wo man als Deutscher würde man nachts niemals hupten. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie gehupt, ich weiss auch nicht, in welchen Situationen jemand jemand hupten solltest, dass du gerade in der, du weisst, dass du auch scheisse fährst, aber gerade auch irgendwie mal so ein bisschen Wut ablassen willst und dachtest, dass das der Lichtschalter, der Blinker wär und dann einfach so aufs Lenkrad aus, da wird schon irgendwas passieren, das ist ja der Nebelschluss in der Fahrprüfung, zeigen wir die Nebelschlussleuchte, Bäm, okay, das war sie nicht.
Das allerlustigste ist ja, wenn jemand ungewollt auf die Hube drückt. Das ist ja immer der beste Moment. Man stirbt zum Beispiel, mit dem Kopf drauf, Däm, das sind die lustigsten Momente. Einfach durchgehend, ja, aber da muss doch jeder lachen, der Notarzt ist vorbei, hat ein kurzes Lächeln auf der Lippe, einfach Bäm, da habe ich doch kein Mensch. Vor allem ist da GTA wirklich sehr realistisch. Weil wenn du die nämlich triffst, die Leute, in Filmen würden die nach hinten fliegen, haben wir schon mal erklärt hier, nein, man fliegt nach vorne. Fallen sie nach vorne, so auf die Hupe. Mit einer großen Kraft fliegen sie die entgegen. Ja, und dann kommen so die, dann kommen so die, dann geht das Autogerät ins Schleudern und auf dich zu und mit der Hupe halt die ganze Zeit, nee, ich muss selber lachen. Und die Eltern, die mit mir GTA gespielt haben, auch. Ja, grossartig. Nee, aber es war tatsächlich sehr anstrengend mit dir in einem Zimmer, weil du wie jetzt gerade auch die ganze Zeit dich beschwert hast, gemäckert hast, hier sprechen so viele Spanisch, ich bin nicht extra hier gekommen, um Spanisch riechende Leute zu hören. Um fliesig Spanisch zu lernen. Die sind ja gar nicht richtig schwarz, die ganze Zeit, die ganze Zeit, du bist zu teuer, mir ist schlecht, ich habe was Falsches gegessen, unterbrochen, dass ich irgendwann gesagt habe, komm Stefan, mach du deinen Scheiss alleine und ich bin mal schön, so gespannt, wo das jetzt hinführt. Einfach mal schön und hat mir gesagt, Leute, zeig mal, was ihr drauf habt. Wie viel hast du bezahlt? 60 Dukaten. 60 Palika, keine Ahnung, wie viel das war. 60 Palika, was? wie viel ist das? Ich habe meine Kreditkartenabrechnung heute mal angeguckt. 950 Lira. Öre. Euro. 950 Euro. Ist es viel, ist es wenig, keine Ahnung. Stimmt, dass das Öre eigentlich so eine Münze war, wo dann noch so zwei Punkte oben drüber waren? Ne, Öhre war Öhre, mir fallen alle meine Öhrengags gerade nicht ein. Aber da hatte ich doch extra vier Dokumente offen mit Öhrengags. Ich habe fünfzig Öhrengags vorbereitet, mir fällt gerade keiner ein. Du bist wohl schwer öhrig. Aber ich würde, das ist mir in der Urlaubtuch, ich würde aber sagen, da war ein Loch drin. Ich weiß, das war der Gag, dass ich so als ob da Ölpunkte drüber wären, das geht ja gar nicht. Du weißt ja viel. Und noch mehr denkst du, dass du alles weißt. Ist das jetzt ein Diss oder was? Das ist ein kleiner Kritikpunkt. Was wir aber noch nicht wussten war, dass es in Amerika Läden gibt, in denen man sich Sachen ausleihen kann. Wir hatten keinen Fernseher in unserer Bude, wie Stefan immer gesagt hat. Wir kommen in unsererude! In unser Nest, unser Liebesnest. In unseren Schuppen! Das war der erste Tag, wir wussten noch nicht genau, wie wir zurückkommen zu unserer Wohnung. Wir wussten, wir sind aus Haarlem, guckt man auch nicht, wie man rauskommt, weil man nur rennt in Tonesang, rennt man aus Haarlem raus, ist dann irgendwann an Times Square. Das wird dem nächsten Weissen entgegen. Und dann ist die Frage, wie kommt man wieder zurück in unser Dorf? Das ist schwierig. Und dann haben wir die U-Bahn genommen, ganz abgespaced, und dann sind wir bei anderen Stationen rausgekommen, als wir erwartet hatten, und dann kamen wir raus, das Licht scheint uns entgegen, wo sind wir hier, und dann erblicken wir diesen einen Laden, Rent a Center. Ich dachte mir, hier kann man ein ganzes Center mieten. Rent a Center, geil. Hat sich dabei herausgestellt. Tatsächlich haben wir den Laden betreten und es stellt sich heraus, man kann alle möglichen Sachen leihen, unter anderem auch Fernseher. Wir hatten keinen Fernseher, hatten da die Idee gefasst, wir leihen uns einen Fernseher. Haben uns dann aber gefragt, welcher Mensch leiht sich einen Fernseher? Also wer ist das normale Klientel dieses Ladens? Fernseher versteht man noch, wenn man irgendwie gerade mal... Ja, da so eine Lampe. Man kann sich einfach Lampen und Städtische, man kann sich so einen ganz kleinen Städtisch einfach mieten. In welcher Welt leiht man sich einen kleinen Städtisch, den man für 10 Dollar oder Öre bei Ikea kaufen kann? 10 Dollar! Ich stelle mir das mal vor, der im Bett liegt und gerade ein Buch liest und das Buch zu Ende gelesen hat und dann so in der Luft hängt und jetzt aber und dann einfach mit dem Schlafentzug in diesem Laden steht und dann so ganz fröhlich so ein Stehtisch unter deinem Arm hat. Ich glaube, das ist so ein typischer Laden, wie man bei Breaking Bad gesehen hat, diese Waschwäscherei, wo die aber wirklich einfach nur eine Geldwäscherei ist, weil du halt, wir sind da reingegangen und die haben uns angeguckt, als hätten sie, als wäre noch nie jemand in den Laden gegangen, als wären wir die, sprich, wir waren die ersten Menschen gewesen, die in diesen Laden gegangen sind. Die haben uns noch angeguckt und die wussten noch nicht wirklich, wie sie mit uns umgehen sollten. Die Fernseher waren auch alle nicht aus, die waren irgendwie so ein bisschen leicht, ne? Die waren aus Pappe, das war die auch. Die waren ein bisschen aus Pappe irgendwie, es war ganz komisch. Eigentlich wollten wir uns so einen Fernseher mieten, um die ganze Zeit irgendwie ProSieben oder so gucken zu können. Ja, die für das hat eigentlich alles nicht mehr. Aber man empfängt ja dann nur diese blöden Sender, wo die diese seltsame Sprache sprechen. Aber dafür, dass es keine Fernseher zu leihen gab, also man konnte sie schon leihen, aber sie waren dann zu teuer, weil man sie mindestens nur für einen Monat hätte leihen müssen und so viel Geld hatten wir nicht. Aber tatsächlich, es gab Fernseher in Taxi, Taxen, in Cabs, Cabby, die gelben Cabs, gab es tatsächlich Fernseher. Das heisst, du sitzt die ganze Zeit ja meistens hinter dem Schutzschild des Fahrenden. Wo man nicht genau weiss, soll der einen vor dem Fahrer beschützen oder soll der Fahrer geschützt werden von den Kunden, man weiss es nicht. Ich habe auch immer angefangen, also ich dachte mir immer, gut, ich bin ein Fahrer, ich suche das Gespräch zu meinem Fahrer und habe dann immer versucht, das rauszureissen, ruckartig, kam nicht so gut an. Du hast dabei deine Pantomime-Vorstellung noch geprobt ein bisschen, kam ganz gut an, glaube ich. Kam nicht so gut an. Dieses gegen eine Fensterscheibe hämmern die ganze Zeit, die gar nicht da ist, ulkig. 20 Minuten lang am Stück, kam mal ganz gut. Ja, kommt gut an. Dann war halt dieser Fernseher vor einem und es war echt mega geil. So wird jede Fahrt eigentlich zu so einem Entertaining-Ding, weil die prokastinieren ja nicht. Selbst wenn die fahren, machen sie ja aktiv was, nämlich nehmen an der Unterhaltungswelt teil. Aber das ist das Geile an Amerika, die nutzen Möglichkeiten, the land of opportunities, sagt man ja auch. The land of undisclosed desires. Zum Beispiel, und jede freie Sekunde wird genutzt, auch wir haben ein Baseballspiel gesehen, jede Sekunde, in der gerade niemand irgendwie einen Touchdown gemacht hat oder so, kam irgendwie eine Werbung und die Nationalhymne wurde einfach nochmal kurz reingespielt und man hat irgendwie Kinder gesehen. Oder die Szene wurde nochmal gezeigt. Genau. Es war schon nicht so schnell, aber es wurde noch langsamer gezeigt. Genau, oder man hat abgeschimmt so, wer in der Halle hat irgendwie mehr Bock auf Handball gerade oder so, wenn mehr als 50 Prozent sind. Oh, Baseball. Schreibt mal kurz Baseball auf, weil jetzt müssen wir nachher noch mal sprechen. Baseball ist ein Riesenthema. Das ist die grosse Baseball- und Rodung-Folge, liebe Leute. Und das muss man sagen, die Amerikaner haben es einfach drauf, irgendwie so diese schrumpfende Aufmerksamkeitsspanne genau auszunutzen. An jeder Ecke, du hast überall Werbung, Neon nicht in dein Gesicht, die ganze Zeit. Es war halt genau an dem Flughafen das Stadion, auch in Deutschland undenkbar, und die ganze Zeit sind im zwei Minuten Tag mega grosse Flieger über uns gefahren. Und ich bin Fl-Fan, Planespotter, hab auch immer die Facts parat. Immer die PS, wie viele Leute, wie viele Leute sind schon gestorben, in wie viele Stadien sind die Flugzeuge schon gefahren. Und es ist halt geil, weil du denkst halt die ganze Zeit so, gut, man hat offensichtlich ein ADHS-Problem, steh ich mir ein, wow, unten wird ein Ball geschlagen, links ist gerade eine Werbung, Gott sei Dank um ein Flugzeug. Aber hab ich eigentlich ADR … oh, da ist ein Flugzeug. Habe ich vielleicht, genau. ADR, oh, ein Hotdog. Man hat keine Chance, ADRs zu bemerken. Aber... Da haben wir immer etwas Neues bekommen. Baseball ist doch eigentlich eine ganz geile Sache. Ich muss sagen, ich habe mich letztens dabei erwischt, wie ich auf YouTube so die zehn, die Best-of-Schläge angeguckt habe irgendwie. Weil Baseball schon eine gewisse Faszinierung sind, weil Baseball ist so ein bisschen so der... Aber haben die nicht auch Platz neun gesagt, ja gut, die anderen … was erwartet ihr noch? Leute, vor 1940 gab es keine Kamera. Ja, okay, alles sorry. Tut mir leid. Wir reden einfach die Pointen heute ineinander rein. Ja. Zwei Pointen zum Zeitpunkt einer. Stefan ist links, ich bin rechts, einfach doppelt die Pointe. Das ist nicht schlecht, das ist nicht schlecht. Aber ab Platz acht hätten die einfach sagen können, gut, alles andere sieht genau gleich aus, Baseball einen guten Schlag, die sehen meistens relativ ähnlich aus, viel Spaß.
Aber ich finde, Baseball ist so ein bisschen die letzte Reihe der Sportarten, die gibt sich nicht so richtig Mühe, was aber sympathisch ist, weißt du, du kennst, Fußball, die Spieler werden für Millionen getradet, die schwitzen richtig, die sprinden auch, die schlagen sich ins Gesicht irgendwie. Undenkbar.
Bei Baseball denkst du, okay, dieses Spiel besteht aus einem Balltreffen und Rennen und die Hälfte des Spiels ist einfach übergewichtig.
Und man denkt sich, ja Leute, wenn die Hälfte deines Jobs Rennen ist, dann renn doch, dann lern doch rennen, das ist doch nicht so schwierig. Es kommt ja schon nicht so oft vor, dass ein Spieler mal den Ball trifft, was ich schon verwunderlich fand. Dann treffen sie einen Ball und dann sprinten sie nicht mehr zur Base. Ich habe dann irgendwann gesagt, gut, ich wette, zehn Leute aus dem Publikum hier könnten besser spielen als die da unten. Warum stehen die da? Ja, ich glaube, die haben auch einen Einten gewechselt irgendwie einfach so, oh, John ist noch auf dem Klo, mal Alva, du mal. Einer aus dem Publikum hat wirklich ins Spiel eingegriffen. Tatsächlich, ganz interessante Situation. Es wurde ein Ball geschlagen und dann hat jemand aus dem Publikum den berührt und dann fiel er aufs Feld, wurde dann jemand dann quasi so brennballmässig ein- und rausgebraucht, es gibt einen Home Run, dass der Ball sozusagen über das Spielfeld hinausfliegt ins Publikum. Da warten auch alle drauf eigentlich im Grunde und stecken sich Hot Dogs ins Gesicht, bis sie dann mal den Ball fangen können. Und da war der Fall, dass es so ganz knapp war und der Ball irgendwie so aufs Geländer gefallen ist. Und ein Kind aus dem Publikum hat den Ball dann irgendwie versucht zu fangen und hat ihn berührt. Und dann ist er aber wieder zurück ins Spiel gefallen. DerType-Type hat ihn dann aufgenommen, zurück an die Base geworfen und dann war die Frage, zählt das jetzt oder nicht? Weil anscheinend, sobald jemand anders als irgendjemand den berührt, auf jeden Fall haben wir dann ganz viel... Die Regeln sind wirklich nicht so ganz klar. Und da musste auch noch der eine Typ in Amerika angerufen werden, der die Regeln kennt als einziger. Hey Paul, pass mal auf, wir haben folgendes. Ich gebe dir mal dieses Kind hier. Herr Ball, wir haben hier ein kleines Problem. I know it's all about that bass, you already told me that, I know, I know, but listen. Und zwar, hat jetzt jemand einen Ball berührt zunächst, dann jemand auf dem Feld wieder, dann dreimal, dann hat er die Dame umgeworfen, dann ist der Läufer auf ein weisses Feld und dann hat er noch Udo gerufen. Dann ist der Schläger in Senf gefallen, wir wissen nicht, was wir machen sollen, können Sie uns doch mal helfen. Dann wird nicht jemand angerufen, das ist aber ganz strange alles. Aber wir haben die ganz oft Zeitlupe gezeigt und anscheinend war die Lösung, also für alle Baseballfreaks da draußen, die jetzt sagen, was ist denn da los? Anscheinend ist die Lösung, dass der Ball dann schon als nicht mehr brennt oder was auch immer gilt, wenn jemand berührt hat und alle, die dann auf den Bases waren, als das Kind den Ball berührt hat, ein Dunking gemacht haben. Genau, durften noch einen Dreier werfen, aber alle anderen nicht mehr, so in der Richtung. Keine Ahnung. Schaut es euch an, es waren die Mets vs Giants, die Mets die New Yorker Band. Gucke ich das nicht an. Die ersten vier Innings haben den 0-0 ausgegangen und es war anscheinend einfach das langweiligste Spiel, was jemals im Baseball stattgefunden hat.
Ich fand es ganz spannend eigentlich. Es hat auf jeden Fall eine Möglichkeit gegeben, in die Regeln zu gehen.
Wenn du das spannend findest, wie findest du dann Desperate Housewives zum Beispiel?
Ganz gut.
Absolut, ja.
Ganz okay.
Macht keinen Vergleich.
Aber findest du es nicht interessant, ein Spiel zu sehen, wo du denkst, ja, das schaffe ich auch, oder? Ja, das ist ganz verwirrend, aber im Fußball bin ich offensichtlich unterlegen. Natürlich nicht, das ist natürlich sehr schwer. Aber trotzdem, es hat so ein, ach, das kriege ich ja auch hin. Ich glaube, sobald du die Regeln verstanden hast vom Baseball, du automatisch zum Spieler wirst. Wie gesagt, dann geht einfach so ein Licht erscheint über dir, sondern dann holen die Leute runter und dann kriegst du einen Schläger in der Hand, einen Handschuh in der Hand, diesen Hut auf, diese seltsame Kleidung an, die aus den 70er-Jahren stehen geblieben sind, kriegst dann Basketball in der Hand und dann sagen die, so Leute, wir haben einen neuen. Apropos, das könnte ich auch, wir waren auch im Museum of Modern Arts, New York.
Ich würde dich ganz kurz noch unterbrechen, weil wir schon mal im Taxi eben waren und es da diese echt strange Sache gibt, dass da nämlich auf dem Bildschirm die ganze Zeit eigentlich so mega gute Laune, Happy Zeug läuft. Links und rechts werden Schwarze erschossen. Und unten links unten einfach so eine Bauchbinde durchläuft, wo die ganze Zeit steht, weiss
nicht, Typ hat drei Leute umgebracht, Typ ist mit brennendem Auto in ein Hotel gefahren, ein Rentner tötet 30 Schüler, aus Versehen, Ops. Das war die beste Nachricht irgendwie, Car crashes in house in Harlem, so, kein Kontext, einfach nur cratched in house. Und die ganze Zeit haben so Todesmeldungen und Tod, Tod, Tod und oben einfach Jimmy Fallon liess die neuesten Tweets vor von seinen Grosseltern oder so. Es war einfach echt grossartig. Und man auch denkt, die versuchen uns gar nicht zu trennen, ihre Probleme und ihre Unterhaltung, sondern die bringen uns einfach effizient zusammen. Aber das ist das amerikanische Modell, glaube ich, einfach süss und salzig zusammen, so einfach so in your face, einfach alles gleichzeitig im Grund. Wir frittieren Oreos, nimm's Stefan. Genau. Ich habe frittierte Oreos, habe ich dir auch eines mitgebracht an dem Baseball. War tatsächlich sehr gut. Ich habe wirklich drei Innings oder so verpasst und es ist einfach normal. Ja, es ist ja auch nichts passiert. Es ist scheißegal. Gut, das ist aber nicht normal, das 0-0-Stand. Aber es ist einfach normal, dass man drei Innings verpasst von neun in dem Spiel. Interessant, damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet, dass Oreos durch den Frittierprozess weich werden. Ich dachte, die werden immer noch hart in der Mitte, aber warum werden die weich,
da kommt doch eigentlich kein Fett rein, dann werden die einfach nur durch die Hitze weich.
Die werden einfach in Fett geworfen halt einfach. Ja, aber mit Teigtum rum. Da bin ich mir nicht
mehr sicher. Doch natürlich. Kann sein. Jedenfalls, da ist auch sehr viel schiefgegangen bei mir,
weil sie hat dann gesagt, wollen sie ein bisschen Puderzucker drauf haben, ich habe gesagt, weil ich es nicht verstanden habe, was ich gesagt habe, weil sie eine andere Sprache gesprochen hat,
habe ich gesagt, ja, habe ich gesagt, jawohl, jawohl, was stimmt, und dann hat sie angefangen, diesen Puderzucker Streuer, hat sie dann drüber gehalten und dann fiel der Deckel ab und ich hatte einfach so einen Berg Puderzucker auf, und dann habe ich gesagt, no, it's enough, it's enough, alle haben sich herrlich amüsiert, ha, ha, ha, supergegs, supergegs, und dann hatte ich halt einen riesen Berg mit Puderzucker, hatte ich dann drauf. Seitdem nimmt man mich in den USA auch den Pudel. So. Du hast ja noch eine neue bekommen, oder? Ne, sie haben das einfach runtergeschaufelt, haben dann die Oreos aus dem Müll geholt dann wieder, haben die auf den Teller gelegt, abgewaschen, über der Zunge aber nur und dann wieder wiedergegeben. Ich habe gesagt, vielen Dank, die sind für Florentin. Du führst auch ein Leben, als wärst du immer in einer Prankshow, oder? Das ist so ein bisschen dein Leben. Aber ich werde geprankt. Also ich moderiere die nicht. Aber es wird vergessen, aufzulösen so. Die haben die Kamera selber vergessen. Oh, da war ja was. Shit. Apropos, das kann ich auch. Wir waren auch im Modern... Das kannst du nicht sagen. Ich dachte, wir schneiden das raus. Das kann ich auch einfach nicht mehr. Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Apropos, das kann ich auch, wir waren im Museum of Modern Arts New York, wo Stefan natürlich wieder alle seine, das sieht ja aus, eine moderne Kunst ist ja scheisse, hau doch jetzt mal ein paar lustige Pointen raus. Einfach für die ganzen Jura-Studenten da draußen, die jetzt mal sagen können, ja, moderne Kunst finde ich auch scheisse. Lass doch mal was hören, Stefan. Nee, ich finde das Museum, Museum, das ist ein TH, das spricht man so aus, of Modern Mards, fand ich sehr lustig. Also es hat mich einfach kulturell angeregt natürlich und dann auch mein Humorzentrum, natürlich, hab da ein paar Tweets rausgehauen, aber jetzt nicht so, ich bin die ganze Zeit da nicht so süffisant grinsend rumgelaufen, sondern ich hab mir jetzt schon meinoguide im Ohr, mit meinem Audioguide bewaffnet, hat auch niemand gesagt, glaube ich, ist rumgelaufen und habe mir dann die Bilder angeguckt, habe mir die Geschichten dazu angehört, überlegt, wow, das war der Künstler damit, klasse, und dann bin ich weitergelaufen. Es gab bei dem Audioguide immer zwei Audiospuren, also zu vielen Bildern gab es dann nochmal so Audiodinger und da gab es eins für Kinder und eins für Erwachsene und ich habe mir immer nur die für Kinder angehört und das war auch interessant. Da waren dann immer so Spiele drin, so nimm drei Schritte zurück und einen nach links und tanze im Kreis und mach deine Hose auf. Und ich schlage das Bild vor dir, das ist eh Crap. Niemand versteht es. Die blöden Erwachsenen verstehen das Bild vor dir auch nicht. Genau, und dann hast du so, woran denkst du, wenn du dieses Bild siehst? An eine Ananas! Und dann hörst du so, wie so eine Ananas durchgeschnitten wird. Oder ich denke an eine Trommel! Dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm. Und ich sitze da vorne und denke mir so, ja man, das sieht echt aus wie eine fucking Trommel. Ich werde drauf rumtrommeln auf das Bild. Also Plastik von so einem Stier einfach. Ja, komm da. Ich finde es auch geil, wenn der Audio-Guide den Kindern so Straftaten verleitet, und man sagt, das sieht doch aus wie eine Trommel, die man jetzt mal benutzen sollte, oder? Das sollte man doch jetzt mal anfassen! Das finde ich immer noch das allererstaunlichste, dass da wirklich Gemälde von Van Gogh und sonstige rumstehen und Lordi und sowas, aber die einfach Tausende und Millionen Dollar wahrscheinlich wert sind, unbezahlbar, und nicht einfach da irgendwie einfach mal sagt, ich mach das kaputt einfach so. Weil es hat schon so, also das sind ja, ich weiss nicht, ob das nicht einfach nicht die echten Bilder sind, aber auf der anderen Seite eigentlich schon, also müssten es eigentlich schon sein, sonst ist es ja ein bisschen albern eigentlich, aber dass man das nicht einfach kaputt macht. Ich meine, Mona Lisa oder so ist ja gross geschützt mit so einer Glasscheibe und so. Das ist eines der bekanntesten Gemälde der Welt. Dieser Hund von Picasso, glaube ich, ist nicht so, ich habe gesagt Hund, obwohl das so ein Ding ist, was sich im Audioguide gesagt hat. Übrigens ist noch nie jemandem der Hund aufgefallen. Schauen Sie mal unten. Das ist aber toll aufgepasst. Deswegen heisst es jetzt in meinem Kopf der Hund, aber der Hund ist komplett Nebensache. Aber hier Van Gogh das mit diesem Midnight in Paris, mit diesem Wirbeln in der Nacht. Wirbeln. Wirbeln. Und so, das könnte man einfach kaputt machen. Dann könnte Woody Allen nie wieder einen Film machen. Das ist einfach, man könnte eingreifen in die Kunstgeschichte. Das passiert ja auch, und dann kommt es bei Nine-Geg mal, wow, die Überwachungskameramann stolpert in ein Bild und macht es kaputt, aber dann restaurieren die das einfach. Ja, aber wenn du es jetzt irgendwie anzündest oder so, dann kannst du es nicht mehr restaurieren. Ja, aber das kann man nicht. Bis du dann Feuerzeug, bis du deine Steine rausgesucht hast, die du mitteilst, um Feuer zu machen, weil du das, was wir sind im Dschungel. Wenn du dann mit einem Messer einfach so ganz oft so durchstichst, dann kannst du das nicht nicht mehr restaurieren, oder? Erst mal kommst du mit einem Messer gar nicht rein. Zweitens, wenn du ein Feuerzeug rausholst, ist schon so ein Security-Guide bei dir. Nein, da war so ein fetter Typ, der mit so einem Kind über Baseball geredet hat, der sich die Regeln erklären hat lassen. Ich meine, wenn du dir in der Cafeteria eine Flasche holst, die irgendwie, also nicht, dass ihr das jetzt machen sollt, aber man könnte sich in der Cafeteria ein Glas holen, das in der Umkleidekabine kaputt machen und dann einfach Van Gogh kaputt machen. Umkleidekabine kaputt machen? Ich war hauptsächlich in der Umkleidekabine eigentlich. Im MoMA. Ja. Und dann, um dir was anzugucken, wo die Darsteller sich verkleidet haben. Die Bilder sich an und dann beraten. Ja, durch das Schlüsselloch. Wo die Bilder Pause machen. Alles sieht durch das Schlüsselloch besser aus, das wissen wir ja wohl. Und da kann man dann einfach so eine Glascheibe nehmen und die Bilder kaputt machen. Aber warum macht das niemand? Es passiert, glaube ich. Aber wirklich, also wirklich zerstören, weil ich meine... Ja, ich habe auch nochmal, irgendwie um Frakturschrift zu lernen, habe ich mal so einen Artikel lesen müssen, damals aus einer ganz alten Zeitung, wo jemand ein Bild kaputt gemacht hat, eine ganz berühmte Szene, wo jemand einfach ein Bild zerstört. Das sind dann berühmte Straftäter, die dann in die Geschichte eingehen, damit man Frakturschrift lernt. Einfach Mike obdachlos mit einer Glasflasche in der Hand. Ja, kann passieren, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht so einfach. Das sind auch überall so Menschen, die dich sehr böse anschauen einfach. Und die haben auch keine Ahnung, wenn du dir über die Kunstwerke was fragen willst, was ich ab und zu versucht habe, Leute anzusprechen, oder auch mal einen Gag zu machen. Da ist ja immer diese schwarze Linie unten, wo ich dann immer meinen Fuss los rübergeschoben habe und immer so rüber geschielt habe, was ein Security-Typ sagt. Du bist wirklich der beste Museumsbesucher, den man sich rüber schreibt. Und man muss immer sagen, die haben dann immer streng geguckt. Es gab auch einen so einen Raum, der ganz abgefahren war. Da gibt es ja die ganzen Klassiker, hängen da herum, die ganzen Gemälde und so die Bilder kennt man. Aber dann gibt es auch immer... Florentin hängt plötzlich auch einmal auf einem Bild, wo ich dachte, was man da oben... Und dann gibt es auch immer so Räume, wo so temporäre Ausstellungen sind und die sind teilweise sehr abgefahren. Und da gab es ja noch einige, wo hauptsächlich so Pappwände durch die Gegend standen, so ganz minimalistische, kleine, irgendwie einfach so eine Dose in der Mitte und so. Aber hauptsächlich Pappwände. So wie man sich moderne Kunst vorstellt, so ganz weird. So einfach so, okay, was ist jetzt Kunst und was nicht. Und da bin ich auch so durchgelaufen und dann war auch so ein Sicherheitsbeamter da und da habe ich auch so angeguckt und der so einfach so zuckt mit der Schulter und so.
I don't know.
Wo ich mir auch denke, es ist doch eigentlich, man stellt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich relativ cool vor,
da Wächter zu sein, weil du den ganzen Tag irgendwie coole Gemälde siehst und dann vielleicht auch irgendwie so eine ganz,
wenn du wirklich jeden Tag vom Loch siehst.
Den ganzen Tag coole Kamele siehst. Das wäre ziemlich cool.
Aber ich glaube, da gibt es schon so eine Hierarchie und der Trottel, der neue,, muss halt dann in dem Abgefahrenen, wo vier Frauen auf dem Boden menstruiert haben, muss da den ganzen Tag rumstehen und sagen, hey, cool, kommt doch rein.
Nee, aber in diesem Raum waren ja ganz viele Pappen einfach aufgestellt und noch nicht befestigt.
Sie waren einfach aufgestellt und ich schwöre dir, ich habe die ganze Zeit gedacht, ich werde derjenige sein, der aus Versehen gegen so eine Pappe läuft einfach.
Weil es ist auch eng. Es sind enge Gänge, die es gebildet hat und es wurde sehr eng und dann bin ich auch oft mit Leuten zusammengestossen und dachte mir, ich schwöre dir. Oh, aber genau das war, was die Künstlerin wollte tatsächlich, dass der Raum verengt wird und man sich so den Bahn, die selbst den Weg durch das Kunstwerk bahnt und auch mit anderen Leuten in Kontakt tritt. Genau das stand da. Und dass man dann gegen so eine Papa fällt, im Gefängnis in Nacht verbringen, das war alles Teil der Experience. Und dass Ed Stefan Tiziosi hier vorbeikommt und in einem schlechten Podcast darüber redet. Das ist Modern Art. Das wir jetzt darüber sprechen. Ja, genau das ist das Kunstwerk. Das gerade ist das Kunstwerk. Müssten wir eigentlich der Künstlerin schicken, aber die bestand nur aus vier Emojis irgendwie, die war ganz postmodern modern. Die Künstlerin ist ein Furby, ganz seltsame. Erinnere mich tatsächlich an meine Zivi-Zeit. Ich habe mit Kindern Zwillings geleistet. Ich finde Zivi klingt immer so ein bisschen lächerlich. Ja, es klingt ein bisschen lame. Ja, aber Hiwi finde ich klingt auch... Azubi, Hiwi, Bundesfreiwilligendienst, Bufagi, nee, warte, sorry, Bundes... Bufraigi. Bufai, nee, Bundes... Bufraidi, Buf... Das sollte man durchsetzen. Bufdi, Bufdi sagt man zu Bundesfreiwilligendienstlein. Doch wirklich, das haben wir ja alles jetzt, wir haben jetzt keine Ziele mehr, wir haben jetzt einen Bufdi. Und ach, denkst du, ey, die Name und der nächste ist dann der Harley oder Kabi. Und dann guckst du auf den Perso und der ist wirklich Bufdi-Müller, schade. Bufdi-Bufdaten. Und da wurde ich tatsächlich, ich war in einer heilpädagogischen Tagesstätte, wo nachmittags Kinder betreut wurden. Du hattest mich bei heilpädagogischen Tagesstätten. Und jetzt kommt, wo Kinder den ganzen Nachmittag alleine gefangen waren. Und da wurde mir auch diese Tagesstätte vorgestellt und da hat jemand gesagt, ja, das ist das Würzburger Konzept, nachdem diese Tagesstätte eingerichtet ist. Und zwar sind viele Wege bewusst enghalten, und gerade vor Punkten, die Kinder interessieren, ist der Durchweg sehr eng. Zum Beispiel vor dem Aquarium ist recht wenig Platz, so dass wenn ein Kind vor dem Aquarium steht und ein Kind irgendwie zu der Schaukel möchte, dann muss es an dem Kind vorbei und muss sagen, kann ich kurz vorbei und muss sozusagen so dadurch mit dem Kind interagieren, um vorbeizukommen. In der Praxis kommt es eigentlich zu viel mehr Konflikten zwischen Kindern. Richtig, du hattest am Ende eine Gruppe von Kindern, die zwar sehr sozial waren, die sehr sozial waren, aber einfach sehr genervt, weil immer Kinder im Weg stehen. Immer im Weg stehen, ja. Alter, geh einfach aus dem Weg! Aber ging es dir in New York auch so, dass du andauernd dachtest, du bist im Weg, dass du einfach dachtest, hier sind sehr viele Menschen in der Stadt, acht Millionen, wann wird es voll und du dachtest, ich bin der Punkt, an mir ist die Stelle erreicht, ich bin zu viel, ich stehe einfach an allem im Weg. Aber sehr höflich, den ganzen Tag, excuse me, sorry, sorry, ich habe das teilweise so stark anzutriert, das ist das erste Wort, das ich mit Leuten, ich gehe zu McDonalds rein und sage, sorry. Es war im Empire State Building, wo wir mit dem Fahrstatt runtergefahren sind, unten ankam Building, unten ankam, der Security guckt uns an, wie die Tür aufgeht und wir beide sorry, sorry, sorry, es ging einfach nicht mehr, es war wirklich am Ende anstrengend. Aber am Ende haben wir dann aber auch angefangen mitzugehen, nicht stehenbleiben, wir hatten selber Termine, Leute rufen uns an, Jimmy fällen will kurz noch mal uns treffen, und dann musst du halt auch selber dann von A nach B kommen schnell, und checks langsam, warum das nervig ist, dass andauernd tausend Elmose auf dich zulaufen, wie in so einem verdammten Fiebertraum laufen fünf Elmose. Oder warum die zehn Franzosen plötzlich anfangen zu singen und eine Revolution zu starten und so. Und dann denkst du, was ist hier los, was soll das eigentlich? So ein schlecht verkleideter Iron Man, wo man sich auch fragt. Der offensichtlich eine Frau ist einfach, wo man sich denkt, es gibt genug weibliche Superhelden, sei Schlumpfine. Aber in einem schlechten Kostüm einfach. Ich hätte ein besseres Batman-Kostüm zu Hause im Schrank stehen. Ja, das wissen wir. Und dann kommt er da in so einem Iron Man-Kostüm, wo ich mir auch dachte, nein, dafür verdienst du kein Geld. Aber die Elmus. Aber eine sehr oberflächliche, aber sehr freundliche Kultur. Ich finde, also ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht und ich finde, Amerika wird ja oft als oberflächlich bezeichnet, das ist es auch, aber das ist auch gut. Es gibt wirklich viele Seiten davon, die wirklich sehr gut sind. Die Amerikaner sind sehr oberflächlich, die Amerikaner sind sehr begeisterungsfähig. Wir waren zum Beispiel mit der Aufzeichnung von Stephen Colbert und da hat man gesagt, das ist einfach ein ganz anderes Erlebnis und es ist einfach brutal, weil die Leute einfach ausrasten. Und du kannst als Deutscher mit der Energie nicht mithalten, ist einfach so. Überhaupt nicht, nein, du bist es nicht gewohnt. Du hast Deutsche ausmachen können nach der Aufzeichnung, weil die einfach da erstmal in einer stabilen Seitenlage am Boden lagen, weil die einfach keine Energie mehr hatten, weil die die ganze Zeit über jeden Gag, wow, ich meine, es geht ja schon weg von Lachen und sich darüber freuen über den Gag, hinzu einfach nur Ekstase, einfach wow, das ist das Beste, was ich jemals gehört habe, Donald Trump, wears a wig, wow, einfach nur ausrasten. Ich glaube, der Amerikaner an sich oder der Klischee-Amerikaner, dem man dabei geht, ist, glaube ich, auch eher gewohnt, Dinge nach aussen zu tragen. Also der immer zeigt, wie es ihm geht, der, wenn er lacht, auch laut lacht und wirklich das auch zeigt, wenn der Deutsche vielleicht genauso viel Freude bei dem Witz empfinden könnte, aber es einfach nicht zeigt, weil der Amerikaner dieses nach aussen gehende outgoing entertainment ding einfach... Aber warum haben sie das Gefühl, nicht richtig wahrgenommen zu werden, weil das wäre dann der nächste Schritt, die werden, man fühlt sich nicht richtig wahrgenommen, deswegen exaggeratet man seine Gefühle. Nee, ich glaube, es ist einfach so eine Oberflächlichkeit, dass wenn man jemand anderem gegenüber tritt, dass man erst mal freundlich, offen und laut und sagt, hey wo kommst du her und geil und lachen und der Warm-Upper zum Beispiel hat irgendwie Leute aus dem Publikum auf die Bühne gezogen. Leute, die es auch wollten offensichtlich. Genau, in Deutschland immer so, ach Gott bitte nicht, Alter, komm lass es vorbei sein, aber da wirklich, hey wo kommst du her und die Leute machen Gag und sagen, ich bin seit zwölf Jahren verheiratet und die Menge, yeah, yeah, yeah, die Zahl zwölf, Traditionell überholte Geschlevermuster, yeah, wow, geil, und alle rasten aus und die Leute haben Bock und der Warm-Uber macht irgendwie einen Gag über Juden und macht Gags über Schwarze und alle lachen sich kaputt einfach. Außer der Schwarze, der ist dann rausgegangen, hat sich umgebracht, aber das ist nahm nicht richtig. Genau, der in den Ketten gelegt wurde, das war ein bisschen strange, aber tatsächlich sehr, sehr coole Stimmung und auch wirklich einfach so ein gewisses Gefühl, komm, wir machen zusammen eine geile Show, ihr seid auch mit dafür verantwortlich, dass die Stimmung geil ist. Das ist aber, das ist ein Punkt. Wir sind beide, also das Publikum ist mit dafür verantwortlich, dass die Sendung gut wird. Das ist, glaube ich, sowas, was wir in Deutschland noch nicht ankommen. Da geht man hin, hat dafür bezahlt und will dann da sitzen und eine gute Sendung sehen. Ja, bring mich mal zum Lachen, unterhalt mich mal. Genau, genau, tu das mal jetzt, das ist dein Job. Das ist Berufswissen einfach. Ja, und da ist es eher so, lass uns zusammen eine geile Show machen, ich habe Bock, dass die Show gut wird. Lass uns eine geile Zeit, Amerika ist viel, lass uns einfach eine geile Zeit haben.
Ja, glaube ich auch.
Die Süßigkeiten sagen das aus, die Leute sagen das aus und Musicals sagen das aus.
Genau, apropos Musical.
Musical.
Man geht nach der Show in ein Restaurant, bestellt sich eine Waffel, isst die Waffel und die Kellner singen einfach Musical-Songs.
Die Kellner steigen einfach über die Tische mit dem Mikrofon und singen einfach
Und dann halten sie das Mikrofon hin und du
Und du singst Happy Ending von Mika, aber weiss ich auch nicht, irgendwas halt, irgendwas
geltsames.
Aber auch sowas, weisst du, einfach dieses Entertainment-Ding zu sagen, okay, Mittagessen ist geil, Waffeln sind geil, Sänger sind geil, Frauen, die wenig anhaben, sind geil. Zwingen wir alle unsere Mitarbeiter jetzt zu singen und die hatten auch nicht wirklich Bock. Das ist auch geil. Das war ein bisschen das Baseball-Phänomen. Nee, das darfst du nicht verfehlen. Ich fand das lustig. Ich weiß, dass du ein lustiges Fan bist, aber das stimmt nicht. Der eine Kellner, der uns, Jeff, der gesagt hat, Hi, Jeff, where are you from? Wenn ich singen durfte, may I give you a water, hat dann, musste dann singen irgendwie, wurde dazu gedemütigt, I will survive zu singen. Und dann stand er da auf unserem Tisch plötzlich und hat I will survive gesungen. Er hat er nicht so richtig gefühlt. Ich glaube, es liegt aber eher daran, dass es in New York einfach einen grossen Überschuss an Musicaldarstellern und Sängern gibt. Denn wahnsinnig viele, das hat man generell das Gefühl, und mal auch später kommen wir auf andere Punkte, aber man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, das gesamte Talent der Welt eigentlich ballt sich in dieser Stadt. Alles ist einfach gut, alles ist grossartig. Die Comedy-Shows, die wir gesehen haben, waren durch die Bank unfassbar und auch die Amateure, die 22-jährigen Anfänger von nebenan waren unfassbar gut. Man hat einfach das Gefühl … Besser als du. Ja, besser als ich, auf jeden Fall. Nicht besser als ich. Schlechter als du. Man hat einfach das Gefühl, da ist so viel Talent in der Stadt und die Leute, die am meisten Talent haben, gehen an Broadway. Und da waren wir am zweiten Abend, glaube ich, um mich mal ein bisschen so durch die Woche zu führen. Wir haben uns herausgeeist aus dem schwierigen Harlem, sind an den Broadway gekommen und haben uns zusammen Les Miserables angeguckt. When the beating of your heart echoes the beating of the drums, where is the night of the beating of the gun, where the slaves again, when the beat... Da fängt es wieder an, aber das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Aber das ist ja wirklich, also Musicals lernt man ein bisschen, liebe Leute, Musicals sind grossartig. Es gibt viele Klischees, aber unterscheinlich, das ist genau wie zu sagen, Subway mag ich nicht. Du kannst dir zusammenstellen, was alles geil ist an einem Sandwich und kannst es dann essen. Und Musicals sind auch geil. Er sagt Musicals, jeder mag Musik, jeder mag Tanz, jeder mag viele Schwule, jeder mag auffallen. Macht dreistündige Vorstellungen. Jeder mag dreistündige Vorstellungen, jeder liebt Theater, jeder liebt Schauspiel. Und es kommt alles zusammen in einem Overflowing-Konzept der Kunst-Musical. Es war echt krass. Also ich habe tatsächlich davor noch nie ein Musical gesehen. Ich wusste grob, was auf mich zukommt, weil Stefan oft auch privat irgendwie mal was hören lässt.
Mal ein Musicalaufwürdig gemacht.
Da war ich schon echt weggeblasen, vor allem also so viel Energie und so viel Kulisse und Aufwand und so in dieser kleinen Bühne und du sitzt da und denkst dir, es kann nicht krasser werden, es kann nicht krasser werden und dann rollen die einfach mal ein vierstöckiges Haus von zwei Seiten auf die Bühne und du hast irgendwie Leute auf vier Etagen, die miteinander singen und du hast Spots und du hast die Beleuchtung, die irgendwie dunsen, Flätter verschlagen werden. Und das ist fucking echte Kanonen, die schiessen dann wirklich einfach. Drei Leute sind gestorben während der Vorstellung, aber es war einfach geil. Die haben sich geopfert, du denkst dir, wow, die tun noch was für die Kunst. Dann haben wir Blackbird gesehen, ein grossartiges Stück, was gerade auch geführt wird, werdet ihr nie in eurem Leben sehen, weil ihr werdet nie in diesen 18 Wochen noch da hinkommen. Dedenfalls, Jeff Daniels und Michelle Williams haben mitgemacht. Michelle Williams, drei Pfarrer Oscar nominierte Schauspielerin, steht einfach mal fünf Meter von dir entfernt und spielt sich die Seele aus dem Leib. Grandios, macht Spaß, supergut. Es war richtig geil, es war richtig, richtig geil. Also kann man echt nicht anders sagen. Und weißt du, du schaust eine geile Show, es war so ein Kammerspiel, also nur zwei Schauspieler in einem Raum die ganze Zeit, und du schaust es ein Stück an und denkst dir, holy shit, ich fühle mich gerade, als wäre ich vergewaltigt worden, weil es so krass war und auch um Vergewaltigung ging. Und dann gehst du einfach raus. Gut, wenn du es einfach weglassen wärst, wäre es echt nicht schlecht gewesen. Ich fühle mich vom Theater vergewaltigt, nächste Bildhotline einfach. Ja, und dann gehst du einfach raus, machst die Türen auf und stehst in New York zwischen Wolkenkratzern und denkst dir, what the fuck, Alter, es wird immer geiler. Ach ja, wir sind ja immer noch in New York. Stimmt, what the fuck. Es ist so, normalerweise geht man in Theater und Filme, um der Realität zu entfliehen, aber in New York hast du das Gefühl, du bist in der Fiktion, öffnest die Türen und du bist in der Realität, die auch geil ist. Das ist so, what, das ist ganz ungewohnt. Und ich muss auch sagen, ich würde gerne folgendes tun. Stell dir kurz folgendes Szenario vor. Ich versammel alle dicken Menschen der ganzen USA vor mir. Sagen wir mal kurz, kommt mal kurz alle zusammen, kommt mal kurz, Heya, Joey, Linden, kommt mal auch Joey von Joey's Pizza, der ist auch dick natürlich,
kommt mal Wendy, der Burger King, Hootas, Huthi, McDonald's, Frau, Frau Donalds, kommt mal alle zusammen. Es ist nicht eure Schuld. Dann nehme ich jeden in den Arm und spiele Good Will Hunting Nas. Es ist nicht eure Schuld, es ist nicht eure Schuld. Jeder Mensch, jeder normale Mensch wird dick in den USA. Auf jeden Fall. Und ich kann es nach dem Aufenthalt dann nicht mehr nachvollziehen, warum es dünne Menschen unter den USA gibt. Das hat mich am meisten gewohnt. Das ist die einzige eigentliche Frage, nicht warum sind die alle übergewichtig, warum gibt es da Leute, die eine normale Figur haben und einfach sportlich sind. Wir waren im Burgerland, Five Guys, super geiler Burger, ich wollte mit dem Burger in der Hand rausrennen und irgendjemanden auf der Strasse fragen, warum bist du nicht fett, warum isst du nicht jeden Tag das hier. Es ist einfach geil. Wie gesagt, es ist alles geil. Wir haben am ersten Abend in ein random Lokal gegangen und ich habe die besten Chicken Wings meines Lebens gegessen. Es war einfach mega krass. Und einfach diese No-Bullshit-Attitüde, es sind einfach geile Sachen. Und nach Tag drei weisst du auch nicht mehr, ist es gerade ein Hungergefühl oder ist es mir einfach nur schlecht? Ja genau, du kennst keinen Hunger mehr. Du hast dieses, es ist schlecht, aber du willst essen. Nee, auch die Tageszeit schreibt dir vor, ähm, Entschuldigung,
du solltest jetzt was essen,
vielleicht aber auch nicht, weil du noch
hungerst, du bist doch, du hast irgendwie
um 16 Uhr was eingeworfen,
vielleicht solltest du nichts mehr essen, aber die Tageszeit gebietet es eigentlich.
Das ist ja ganz seltsam, so die Tageszeit
macht dich fertig. Und sobald das Essen vor dir steht, denkst du,
geil, Alter, das ist richtig geil.
Okay, richtig entscheidend. Und dieses das Geilste von allen zu haben,
Amerika hat ja irgendwie, man sagt, man oft hat keine eigene Kultur in der Hinsicht, weil es nicht so alt ist, die holen sich einfach das Geilste aus allen Ländern, da gibt es dann irgendwie Hot Dogs und Pizza und alles und einfach dieses Schmeiss alles zusammen und einfach, hey, Cola ist geil, Vanille-Eis ist geil, wir servieren dir Cola mit einer Kugel Vanille-Eis drin, einfach so dieses Coke-Float. Ja, Float, ja, einfach diese Bullshit-No-Bullshit-Attitshit-Attitüde. Was wir auch in unserem YouTube-Video, was wir zum ersten Mal gemacht haben, könnt ihr online angucken, was wir auch schon gesagt haben, Cherry Coke ist geil, Vanilla Coke ist geil, man kann sich auch nicht entscheiden, machen wir es einfach zusammen! Und es wird daraus Metzomix. Das war die grösste Überraschung. Sehr hitzearm. Es ist wirklich krass, es gibt unfassbar viele Variationen von allem. Ich glaube, von gibt mehr Variationen von einem Produkt, als es in Deutschland Produkte gibt. Es gibt einfach Cornflakes, und in Deutschland gibt es fünf Cornflakes, und in Deutschland gibt es einfach fünfzig, in New York fünfzig. Auch Oreos gibt es in Deutschland nicht mehr in jedem Supermarkt, da gibt es sie zum Dippen, unreversed, double, peppermint, reversed, reversed, reversed, diet, diet, reversed. Was wäre einedecker die Hälfte, Doppeldecker die Hälfte, Doppel nur Creme, Creme mit Doppelkeks, alles einfach, es gibt alles. Ja, vor allem auch zum Dippen und zum Überbacken und zum Frittieren und man nennt sich dann irgendwann auch, ja. Und dann gibt es nochmal fünf Eissorten, dann gibt es nochmal Eis nur mit Creme, Eis mit Doppelschokolade, Doppelschokolade, Doppelschokolade, Doppelschokolade. Die ersten vier Tage im Supermarkt verbracht, nur vom Oreo-Stand. Und wenn man sich denkt, ja ja ja, ja, die Amerikaner, ja, Süsskram können sie, ne, und dann hier wieder alles Plastik. Auch die Fleischabteilung. Du gehst als, du denkst, du bist, okay, du bist als Deutschland, Deutschland Land der Metzger und schlechter, gehst du in so eine Fleischabteilung und denkst, ja, Leute, dann grab mich ein einfach, dann ist es mir auch egal. Ja, vor allem so Riesensteaks einfach, die fertig sind, in die Pfanne zu hauen. Riesensteaks, krasses Zeug einfach. Dafür müsstest du in Deutschland echt zum Metzger gehen, das haben die da einfach geil. Und dann aber denkst du auch, du kommst aus dem Land der Brote, der Bäcker. Und du hast recht, in Amerika haben die nur Bagels, aber es gibt nur Bagels, aber die sind geil. Die Getränke, es gibt wieder hundert verschiedene Erfrischungsgetränke, es gibt alles mögliche, es gibt Melonenlimonade, es gibt Apfellimonade, es gibt allen möglichen Scheiss. Es ist wirklich krass.
Nein, es ist was anderes als Apfelschorle.
Es ist das Exotische, was gerade eingefallen ist.
Apfellimonade ist was anderes als eine Apfelschorle.
Ach, halt die Fresse.
Abgespaced.
Die habe ich gekauft, aber bin nicht mehr dazugekommen, sie zu trinken, weil ich so viel Root-Bier trinken musste.
Auch Eistig gab es da ganz abgespaced.
Wahnsinn.
In Kanistern.
Es gab wahnsinnig viele Sachen, wahnsinnig coole Sachen, wo man sich immer fragt, warum wird das nicht in Deutschland verkauft?
Es ist doch einfach geil. Pop-Tarts. Ich verstehe nicht, warum sich das in Deutschland nicht durchsetzen. Weil das Freihandelsabkommen heißt doch jetzt eigentlich, finden wir das doch jetzt gut, oder? Freihandelsabkommen ist doch so, die ganzen Regelungen in der EU, die wir alle gerade so toll finden, wow, werden vielleicht ein bisschen gelockert, damit wir mit den USA besser handeln können. Aber im Prinzip sind diese Regeln doch einfach nur übersetzt, also es sind doch einfach nur Juristen deutsch für, wir dürfen weniger Pop-Tarts essen. Und wenn man ein Freihandelsabkommen wäre, heisst gleich mehr Pop-Tarts. Das ist die einfache Regelung, könnt ihr euch mal merken, wenn ihr überlegt, bin ich gegen TTIP, bin ich für TTIP, ich weiß es nicht genau. Genau, wenn ihr euch morgen wieder in die nächste Eisenbahngleis-Haltestelle kettet gegen TTIP, könnt ihr mal nachdenken, was habe ich eigentlich gegessen, war das eigentlich so in Ordnung? Das heißt, es ist weniger Pop-Tarts. Ob das so gut ist, denkt einmal darüber nach. Cornflake, Alter. Die Fruit Loops, weißt du, das klingt jetzt so 90s, irgendwie, man muss dabei gewesen sein, ich liebe Alf-mässig. Aber falls ihr euch daran erinnert, wie Fruit Loops als Kind geschmeckt haben, dieses Zucker mit Plastik mit Zuckerguss, das ist einfach genau so schmecken in Amerika die Fruit Loops einfach heute noch. So einfach dieses zuckerige, künstünstliche. Und weißt du, in den deutschen, dann schaue ich mir die deutschen Fruit Loops an, dann steht da mit natürlichem Farbstoff. Und ich denke, Alter, du hast Fruit Loops einfach nicht verstanden, darum geht es nicht mehr Fruit Loops. Wenn du Sünde willst, dann gib mir die sündigste Sünde der Welt einfach. Und das hat New York verstanden oder Amerika einfach verstanden. Und Louis C.K., der sagt, in Amerika geht es eigentlich nicht beim Essen, sondern darum, sich selber am meisten zu hassen. Richtig, es geht um Selbstvernichtung.
Selbstaufgabe. Ja, Selbstvernichtung. Es geht darum, wir hatten dieses Frühstück, alter Vater, diese Pancakes.
Das war der Tag, wo ich dachte, ich habe einen Herzinfarkt, oder? Ohne Scheiss. Also wir hatten das Frühstück erst morgens, mir ging es noch nicht so gut an dem Tag, weil ich, weiß ich nicht warum.
Ich glaube, das hat damit zu tun, was der Pointe zu tun. Genau märz haben verloren und dann und dann haben wir halt uns morgens einfach mal bagels reingestopft mit geilen rührei und bacon oder noch pancakes mit bacon warum nicht man kann es mir mal bacon bestellen die kellnerin guckt eigentlich komisch an hier würde man auch sagen sie haben schon bacon bei den bei den bagel dabei ist schon klar oder es kam diese frage kommt dann nicht weil sie auch einen nicht versteht sie Spanisch spricht, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Und dann haben wir da sehr viel bekommen und dann dachte ich wirklich, da sind wir nachmittags durch den Central Park flaniert und dann habe ich echt gedacht, ich habe einen Herzinfarkt, weil mein linker Arm taub wurde. Wo ich mir auch dachte, davor war ich in Disney-Stores, lief der Star-Wars-Soundtrack, ich habe ein cooles Shirt an, ich kann sterben im Central Park in New York, Wäre nicht schlecht. Kann ich sterben jetzt. Ich bin meinen linken Arm nicht mehr, wahrscheinlich ist gleich vorbei. Und ich habe auch nicht mehr, das war der erste Moment, wo ich dachte, ich sterbe und ich weiss warum. Also ich habe mich nicht gefragt, warum, ich bin doch so jung, warum sterbe ich gerade, sondern ich dachte mir, okay, du hast echt viel gefressen die letzten Tage. Schuldig sterben ist doch das, was man will. Ärzte würden nicht vor einem Rätsel stehen, wenn sie sagen, okay, er ist ein 21er gestorben, warum?
er hatte noch drei Bacon im Mund, es ist relativ offensichtlich, aber auch da zu sagen, einfach wir servieren Pfannkuchen mit Bacon, in Deutschland, was, das ist ja total ekelhaft, aber da einfach nie, no bullshit, Pfannkücher, Bacon, einfach Sirup über alles, Butter über alles, Bagel drauf und es ist geil und es ist auch geil, einfach zu sagen, alles Coole wird kombiniert und das ist der richtige, das ist der way to go.
Das ist einfach und es ist ja auch einfach geil. Es schmeckt einfach gut an diese Sausages, diese English Breakfast Sausages, die man in Deutschland nicht kriegt, die mega geil sind, diese Frühstückswürstchen.
Ich habe mich gedacht, ich liebe Erdnussbutter, ich bin ein riesen Erdnussbutter-Fan, da dachte ich mir, warum gibt es nicht irgendwas, was einen legitimiert, nur Erdnussbutter zu essen, ohne Brot, ohne alles, was haben die da? So kleine Cupcakes, die Schoko, Schoko einfach nur und dann drin ist einfach nur Erdnussmutter. Das ist einfach, einfach okay, ja, was könnte man noch machen? Wir machen es einfach. Das ist einfach die, wir machen es einfach, die Idee. Und dann noch diese krassen Stores irgendwie. Weißt du, New York. Ja, aber das ist, glaube ich, ein New York-Ding, das ist kein Amerika-Ding. Times Square, der M&M-Shop zum Beispiel. M&M World. M&M World, alle M&Ms der Welt. Man denkt ja vor allem, M&M World, ist es wirklich eine World oder reicht die einfach einen M&M-Shop? Weil M&M, sagen wir mal ehrlich, die Welt ist relativ begrenzt. Es sind kleine Dinge mit Zoko drin. Es sind kleine Planeten drin. Nein! Nein, es gab alle M&Ms, erstmal alle Sorten, dann nochmal alle in allen Farben, die grossen, die kleinen, die mittel, alle nochmal in allen Farben. Dann gab es M&Ms mit Erdbeer, M&Ms mit Mandelhonig, mit Pfefferminz, alle die gleiche Schlüsselanhänger, M&M Einkaufswagenchips, M&Ms Kugelschreiber, M&Ms, M&Ms. Und ich dachte mir einfach, ja M&Ms, wo ein Bild von einem M&M drauf ist. Wahnsinn. Wo ich mir einfach dachte, okay, M&M T-Shirt, richtig geile Idee. Ich will einfach so ein T-Shirt in einer Einfarbe, wo so ein M draufsteht in Weiss, dass ich so selber aussehe wie ein M&M. Wie ein weisses M&M. Gab es einfach nicht, gab es nicht. Es gab immer nur T-Shirts mit so einer M&M-Figur drauf, aber einfach nur mit diesem weissen M. Warum verkaufen wir es nicht? Das wäre das beste T-Shirt. Also bunte T-Shirts mit einem weissen M drauf. Genau, wenn ihr bei Spreadshirt zuhört, einfach mal dieses M und M-M einfach auf ein T-Shirt hauen. Können wir doch das Design machen für uns, weil wir haben ja den Fehler gemacht, dass wir das Design, unser Podcast-Uvo-Design, haben wir nicht angegeben, dass wir da was bekommen. Wir verdienen tatsächlich nichts. Das heißt, wir haben an Spreadshirt nichts verdient leider. Grosster Fehler, könnt ihr bei Patreon wieder gut machen. Wir können es jetzt aber auch nicht ändern, denn wir können jetzt nicht sagen, ja, jetzt kosten sie 10 Euro mehr. Doch, habe ich unmerklich gemacht. Also wegguckt das einmal. Da habe ich mir kurz gesagt, ich gehe mal kurz raus. Ich bin den ganzen Tag nur auf unseren Spreadshirt. Hol mal kurz draussen nochmal fünf Bagels, die wir uns reinpfeffern können. Falls ihr euch fragt, was ihr eurem Liebsten zum Frühlingsanfang schenken wollt, hey Schatz, T-Shirt-Phase, es geht wieder raus, schenk ihm so einen kleinen, ähnlich aus dem Podcast-Ufo Weihnachtsbären, der immer noch im Store erhältlich ist. Für 13,99 Euro. Und wenn ihr sagt, ey geil, ich will Geld ausgeben, hab mir eigentlich gar nicht so Lust, irgendwas dafür zu bekommen, dann geht auf Patreon, da könnt ihr uns einfach Geld gehen, ohne, dass ihr euch damit rumschlagen müsst, dass ihr irgendwas dafür bekommt. Aber ihr könnt es von der Steuer absetzen, glaube ich, vielleicht nicht genau, wir kennen uns nicht mit Steuern aus, ich habe riesige Steuerproblemee. Das Ende der Folge. Redaktionelle Unschlüssigkeit. Die Redaktion hat sich kurz eingemischt in die Folge. Was war denn, was war denn, was war das? Ich habe es nicht genau verstanden, was du machen willst.
Die Top drei was? Erlebnisse?
Die Top drei Erlebnisse aus New York.
Zum Abschluss einfach die Top drei Momente aus New York.
Der dritte Moment.
Mein erster Bagel.
Mein zweiter Moment.
Als ich dachte, ich hätte den Baseball gefangen, aber es waren in Wirklichkeit nur dein Kopf und Platz und der erste Platz, ähm, der Rückflug. Mein Platz Nummer drei, der Hinflug. Ich bin noch nie übers Meer geflogen, ich bin noch nie so lange geflogen, es war richtig geil, man muss sagen... Und du bist gefucking flogen. Ich bin geflogen. Ich habe es nicht geglaubt, bis das Flugzeug abgehoben ist, aber wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft zu fliegen in einem zweistöckigen Flugzeug, mit fast bei vielen Menschen drin. Mit mehr als 1000 PS, 835 Passagiere, passende Reihen, 16 Notausgänge, der Airbus A388 war das glaube ich, in dem wir geflogen sind, Lufthansa, eine bekannte, die ganzen Facts habe ich rausgehauen, die Stewardess. Zum Glück war ich nicht in Reichweite. Und dann der Anflug auf New York. Ich weiss nicht, ob ihr es wisst, ob ihr auch mal da New York geflogen seid. Aber wenn man auf New York anfliegt, dann ist es ja so, dass man einmal über die Stadt fliegt und dann so eine ganz grosse Kurve übers Meer macht und dann nochmal anfliegt auf den Flughafen. Und ich saß bei dieser riesigen Kurve, saß ich genau rechts sozusagen, also mit Blick auf die Stadt und das Flugzeug hat sich so geneigt und ist halt einmal rund um die Stadt geflogen und ich konnte ganz New York sehen. Ich könnte das gerade nicht sehen, aber er macht gerade hier so einen Tanzwetter auf, Sonnentanz aus Yoga, aus dem Musical Yoga. Ja, ich hatte David Guetta auf dem Ohr und habe New York gesehen, einfach es war ein Traum, es war ein absoluter Traum. Und dann, als wir geflogen sind, war ja Nacht tatsächlich, wir sind die Nacht durchgeflogen und da saß ich auch nochmal am Fenster auf der richtigen Seite und es war auch nochmal dieser Kreiselflug über New York, aber halt New York bei Nacht und das Lichtermeer und die ganzen Türme und die kamen immer näher und es war toll. Ich habe beim Anflug auf Deutschland habe ich Wagner gehört, der war Kührenritt und es war wirklich, also ich dachte mir kurz so, AfD wählen kann man schon mal machen. Es ist schon ganz geil Deutschland zu sein, wenn du Wagner im Anflug, vor allem weil du, dir fällt, mir ist wieder ist wieder mal aufgefallen, wie viele Windräder es hier gibt und wie wenig Windräder es in den USA gibt. Das ist richtig, ja. Und die machen da einfach richtig viel Strom, weil die andauernd an sind. Und dann fliegt man darüber, schwebt man weg und hört Wagner. Mach das mal. Platz Nummer zwei. Ja. Weiss ich nicht, aber Platz Nummer eins, ich sage nur, ich habe Diabetes, deswegen huste ich jetzt sehr viel, hustet man beim Diabetes, ich weiss nicht, ich glaube schon, man hustet Zucker, man hustet Süßstoff, Platz Nummer eins war natürlich, ass money, ass money, ass money, oh, that might sound funny, but it was not funny at all, because I lost five dollars. They call me Es-money, because I got a lot of bling bling. It might sound funny, but it doesn't, because I lost five dollars at all. So tell me what happened, Mr Es-money did. I already did that in our Video-Podcast. Ja, aber mach's doch mal. Ich habe 15 Dollar an zwei Schwarze gegeben, die gesagt haben, danke, dass du mich erstmal ausreden lässt, obwohl ich Schwarzer bin als Deutscher. Fand ich schon lustig, muss ich lachen, fand ich toll. Dann hat er gesagt, ich habe eine CD, musst du die mal hören? Ich dachte mir, wow, er schenkt mir eine CD, wer macht das denn in Deutschland, habe ich noch nie eine CD geschenkt bekommen. Er hat gesagt, wow, wie heisst du, Stefan, oh, I'll call you as money, ich komplett hin und weg, in den Augen verloren, dieses schwarzen Mitbürger, mit seinen tief schwarzen Augen, keine Pupillen, aber nur schwarze Augen. Aber es ist auch ein subtiler Trick, schon mal jetzt Geld anzusprechen, so dass du denkst, stimmt, ich habe echt eine Menge Geld. Er hat sich aber ein bisschen lustig gemacht. Rückblickend hätte man da schon schlutzig werden können, als er sagt, du heisst as money, as I will get you all my money. Wer hätte schon schutzig werden können, als du angesprochen wärst und wir alle fluchtartig einfach weggerannt sind. Und dann kichernd in so einer Ecke von so einem Einkaufsladen stand, wo ich mir auch dachte, geil, die hätten mich auch ernsthaft vergewaltigen können da auf der Strasse, die hätten mir das Portemonnaie aus der Hand reissen können, ihr hättet an dem Rand gestanden und dann hättet ihr bestimmt auch nachher euch ein bisschen geschämt dafür. Naja, und dann habe ich dem Geld gegeben für sein Video, weil er sagt, er hat ein Video gemacht, dann kamen 15 andere an, die gesagt haben, ja gut, dann wollen wir aber auch Geld haben. So funktioniert es ja auch, wenn du Geld für ein Album ausgibst, kommen alle anderen Musiker mit Berechnung zu dir. Dann kommt Drake Harvey. Dann will ich als Drake auch Geld haben. Dann kommt David Guetta, dann kommt Justin Bieber. Leute, habe ich erst mal gefragt, habt ihr Paypal vielleicht, wenn ich dachte, ich komme auf die schlaueste Nummer raus, nope, ja dann haben wir, hatten sie, dann gib mir kurz ein Handy, damit ich mir jetzt mal einschaffen kann.
Ich habe gesagt, nein, ich gehe jetzt los, dann musste ich den anderen die CD wiedergeben, durfte nur die CD behalten von dem, dem ich vorher fünf Dollar gegeben hatte, und dann bin ich zu euch lachenden wichtigen.
Wie hat dir denn das Album gefallen, von diesem Original-NY-Rapper-Dude?
Von denen, wie ich erinnere, 15 Songs ist der eine, der drauf ist, ein Virus. Aber der ist sehr gut. Wir haben eine Menge Geld überwiesen. Aber der klingt echt toll. Ha ha ha, ha ha ha, wir haben den Computer gehackt. Idiot, idiot, idiot, loser. Ja, ist ein guter Song. Ja, ist ganz geil. Das war toll, ne, in New York. Mach mal nochmal. Hättest du Lust, da zu leben eigentlich? Vor allem danach sind die nochmal zu mir gekommen, ich bin da öfter lang gelaufen am Times Square, auch um die zu provozieren, bin ich noch ein paar Mal lang gelaufen. Und dann haben die gesagt, hier, gerade das ID, gerade das ID, it's free. Und dann habe ich mir gesagt, nein, no, it's not, it's not free. Die können das ja anwerben, wie wir es bei mir auch gemacht haben, mit Wahrheiten, aber mit so einer Lüge, das ist uncool. Das ist richtig uncool. Was auch uncool ist, ist... Was ist noch... Was, wieso? Das Ende der Folge. Ach so, echt, ist es? Ja. Guck mal, wie lange wir noch... Wow, die knackigste Abmoderation aller Zeit an der Stelle. Ja, das war unser kleiner Ausflug nach New York. Wir haben bestimmt noch eine Menge zu erzählen und viel vergessen, dass wir in anderen Folgen nochmal anreisen können. Habt ihr Fragen? Habt ihr Antworten? Wir sind mehr an Antworten, als an Fragen. Habt ihr neutrale Sätze, an die jeder was Fragen noch beantworten? Ich glaube, wir sind der einzige Podcast, der mehr Fragen aufwirft, als die Zuschauer Fragen haben. Deswegen können wir auch kein FAQ machen. Wir können beantworten und uns mal Fragen vielleicht. Obwohl, eine Seite, wir haben ja noch ein bisschen was angeteasert, was diese Woche passiert ist, denn das Schicksal des Podcasts stand auf Messers Schneide dieser Woche, denn eines Tages wuchen wir auf und stellten zu unserem aller Erschrecken fest, dass die Seite down war. Podcast-Ufo.fail. Ich hab dir erstmal eine SMS geschrieben, eine sehr schockierte, mit sehr vielen Großbuchstaben, zurückkam nichts. Irgendwann am Laufe des Tages hab ich gefragt, übrigens, du weißt schon, das ist mir auch dann vergessen, habe ich dann gefragt, du weißt schon, dass unsere Seite down ist und dann, oh, ja, ups. Lass uns über Stephans SMS-Verhalten reden. Stefan schreibt sowas wie, Stefan sieht, dass die Seite down ist und schreibt, ist unsere Seite down, wo die Antwort lautet, ja, schau nach, du Depp, ob die Seite down ist. Wenn du mir sagen willst, dass die Seite down ist, dann schreib, hey, unsere Seite ist down. Aber da habe ich sofort keinen Bock mehr zu kommunizieren, wenn du schreibst, ist unsere Seite down? Wenn du es weisst, dass sie down ist. Ja, das ist eine Suggestivfrage. Ich will nämlich, dass du sagst, ja, sie ist down und ich werde es ändern, dass du, während du die Antwort aussprichst, dir auffällt, dass du einen Fehler gemacht hast. Weil der Fehler lag natürlich bei dir. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Nicht wirklich. Im Nachhinein überhaupt nicht. Wir haben dann nämlich geistesgegenwärtig, haben wir unseren, erstmal muss man sagen, wir dachten erst, es liegt aber ein anderes Problem, weil die Puff-O-Pedia ist auch down, aus dem Grund, weil sie überlaufen wurde von Bots, Der hat mittlerweile uns der Server-Hoster, also der komplett Domainfactory.de, war anscheinend auch Messerschneider. Die ganze Existenz der Firma hat gewackelt, weil Pufopedia unterlaufen wurde, weil wir es verkackt haben, Administratorenrechte zu klären. Ich krieg ja immer, wenn da auf der Seite irgendwas nicht läuft, krieg ich eine Mail, irgendwie so eine Fehlermeldung. Und es war tatsächlich auch in New York so, dass ich wirklich pro Sekunde bestimmt fünf bis sechs Mails bekomme.
Würde ich, pro Sekunde, immer, jede Sekunde habe ich fünf bis sechs Mails bekommen. Und irgendwann habe ich eine Mail von unserem Host bekommen, der gesagt hat, wir mussten leider diese Funktion abschalten, weil unser Server überlastet ist mittlerweile. Und er hat gesagt, okay, cool, kann man auch machen. Man sieht das AKW neben Domain Factory nochmal richtig pumpen. Da müssen wir noch ein paar Kohlen- und Uranstäbe einfach in den Schlot werfen. Ja, hast du gemerkt, dass AKW und Kohle nicht so ganz zusammenfasst. Auf jeden Fall haben wir uns gesagt, ja, ich kümmere mich drum, wissend, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das macht. Auf jeden Fall haben wir jetzt angerufen und haben gesagt, hey, was ist da los, unsere Seite ist down. Das war eigentlich unangenehm. Und haben mit einem sehr netten Support, mit einem jungen Herrn von der Support gesprochen, das allerdings relativ unangenehm wurde, denn ...
Er hat irgendwann gesagt, ja, der Grund für das Problem liegt in einer Tabelle, die sich nicht aufbaut, mit dem Namen und man hat echt gemeldet, es war ihm unangenehm, was er sagen wollte, wird uns natürlich keine Schuldbewusst, ja, da baut sich eine Tabelle nicht auf, die heisst WP-Sex.
Wie gut ist das denn? Das ist der beste Name einer Tabelle. Also WP steht für WordPress, unsere Seite steht ja WordPress, aber es ergibt keinen Sinn, diese Datei existiert nicht, es gibt keinen Sinn, aber es klingt so lustig, einfach so dieses klassische, ja, meine Festplatte ist voll, was können Sie machen, ja, da ist hier russenschlampen.aol.de hat hier 16 GB. Und das in der einfachsten Form, Sex, WP. Einfach nur Sex. Es ist nicht so wirklich unangenehm, nur so ein bisschen und die hätten sich mehr Mühe geben können. Es war nämlich, irgendwer hat uns gehackt und hat dann einen Beitrag erstellt. Ja, wir wissen bis heute nicht genau, was passiert ist, aber es ist auch ein mysteriöser Beitrag auf unserer Website erschienen, den nicht wir gepostet haben. Mit Inhalt Y einfach nur. Ja, ganz seltsam. Und WP-Sex. Das ist wirklich lustig, dass er auf seinem Bildschirm hatte, dass er zwei Dödelrufen
an, die irgendwie ganz am Kichern waren, und er nahm eine Tabelle mit dem WP-Sex.
Ja, vor allem, ich stelle mir vor, der scrollt so durch alle Dateien überall, wunderbar,
gut, nur bei einem ist ein riesiger roter Balken so, Achtung, Gefahr, überlastet, WP-Sex.
Einfach die beiden, wir kichelnden Jungfrauen am anderen Ende so, hihi, was, das können wir uns, das ist Stromberg, so, was, das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, was, das darf man ja nicht, diese Tabellen soll man ja auch gar nicht öffnen. Klassischste Ausrede, so, nö, das muss ein Hacker für uns erstellt haben.
Da habe ich kein gesagt.
Da habe ich auch gesagt, es wäre super, wenn sie das wieder hinbekommen könnten.
Wir machen einen Podcast und das ist alles ziemlich tragisch. Ja, und er hat gesagt, kein Problem auf diese Frage. Dieses hoch rationale Technikgespräch bringt Drama Stefan plötzlich eine andere Ebene rein, so, ja, das wäre echt tragisch, wir haben da seit Jahren dran gearbeitet und wir haben zwei Hörer und einer davon ziemlich uncool. Aber er meinte, er hat auch einen Blog. Er hat auch einen Blog, ja. Dann war das Gespräch kurz davor, abzudriften in, und wie heißt dein Blog so, und was machst du da? Ja, Katzenfutter.org. Judenschlampen, ja, nicht so wichtig. WP-Sex heißt mein Blog. What? Oh mein Gott, gotcha! WP.sex. Aber echt seltsam. Ich habe kurz ein anderes Bild im Kopf gehabt, dass man da eine Tabelle leuchtet. Und zwar, der Serveranbieter muss ja geguckt haben, okay, alle unsere Server sind überlastet, alle unsere Seiten sind down, wir sind für die meisten im Internet verantwortlich, wo ich das Problem und die suchen und suchen und suchen und dann einfach so eine dunkelige Pufopedia. Was ist das überhaupt? Was ist eine Pufopedia? Was soll das? Wir schauen mal drauf. Stefan, schweer! Und wir müssen jetzt Feedline at Punchline in die Mail schreiben, dass unsere Existenz bedroht ist. Es ist ein toller Scherz. Wo ist die Kamera? Das ist der genialste Hacker, den ich je gesehen habe. Feedline at Punchline.de. Schnitze mir mit einem Stück Butter vor dem Rechner. Klickick einfach, adminrechte brauche ich nicht, wollen sie die Seiten löschen können, ne, passt schon, kein Problem. Das Wort kenne ich nicht. Das war schrecklich, also für alle, die heute diese Woche gebangt haben, Geburtstag haben, Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday an unserer Stelle, ein besonderer Gruß geht raus, Stefan, du hast noch ein paar Patreon-Nachrichten vorbereitet, die wir vorlesen können. Wir haben keine bekommen, glaube ich.
Aber falls ihr erwähnen wollen möchtet, am Ende der Folge, die eh keiner mehr anhört,
dann könnt ihr es über Patreon spenden.
Ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine ganz fantastische Woche.
Falls wir wieder mal down sein sollen, seid euch gewahr, wir kämpfen vor euer und unser Recht. Man sagt nicht, die Seite ist down, man sagt, die Seite hat Trisomie 21.
Steine Gag am Rande.
Tschau!
Bis dann, macht's gut, tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal, ihr mal.